[Rires]
[Musique]
tout de suite sur Public
Sénat bonjour à tous très heureux de
vous retrouver en direct sur Public
Sénat ici à la Porte de Versailles à
Paris où se tient le 105e congrès des
maires de France organisé par l'AMF
l'Association des maires de France les
équipes de Public Sénat sont mobilisées
cette semaine pour vous faire vivre
l'événement et décrypter les défis
auxquels doivent faire faire doivent
faire face nos maires au quotidien et
parmi ces défis il y a la question du
logement le secteur connaît une crise
qui s'accentue cette année avec une
baisse de la construction une hausse de
la demande et une hausse également des
taux de crédit immobilier pour en parler
j'accueille sur ce plateau Corine jolie
bonjour
vous êtes présidente du site pap.fr
particulier à particulier site d'annonce
immobilière j'accueille également maider
arostegi bonjour vous êtes maire les
républicains de Biaritz sur ce plateau
également pierremic bonjour vous êtes
maire écologiste de Bordeaux et puis
bonjour à vous tiré Repentin vous êtes
maire d'ivers gauche de Chambéry en
charge des questions de logement au sein
de l'association des mers de France et
vous êtes également président de l'ANA
l'Agence nationale de l'habitat alors
avant débuté nos échanges sur cette
crise du logement où les maires sont en
première ligne et bien nous allons voir
un reportage de notre journaliste
Mathias araes qui est allé à la
rencontre du maire de Fontenis sous-bois
dans le Val de Marne un maire qui tente
tant bien que mal de trouver des
solutions pour faire face à cette crise
du logement à Fontenet sous-bois
Jean-Philippe Garay prend la question du
logement à bras le corps on construit
250 logements trois équipements une
crèche une nouvelle médiathèque un
nouveau centre de santé et dedans il y
aura % de logements sociaux et 70 %
d'accession pour répondre au besoins et
de logement et de rénovation dans sa
commune où toutes les classes sociales
sont représentées le maire constate que
personne n'est épargné nous on fait
partie des villes où les projets ne
s'arrêtent pas mais il y a des endroits
où les projets s'arrêtent faute
de pas de trouver des des gens qui
veulent accéder à un logement mais parce
que les banques refusent leur prêt et
donc ça plus la crise du logement social
euh ouais c'est dur en ce moment pour
nous de vivre la crise du logement parce
que aujourd'hui on a évidemment les
classes populaires qui connaissent la
crise depuis longtemps on on a
maintenant les classes moyennes pour qui
c'est dur mais malgré la crise qui
couvere l'élu en poste depuis 2016
refuse la fatalité et prô le
volontarisme on est un certain nombre de
maires apportter cette question là pour
trouver des solutions à nos habitants et
donc c'est important qu'on continue à
nous construire 30 % de plus de 30 % de
logements sociaux dans toute nouvelle
opération c'est aussi inventé innoveré
on a des opérations avec du bail réel
solidaire c'est la déconnexion entre le
le prix du foncier le foncier
n'appartient pas à ceux qui achètent
mais un office foncier solidaire il est
mutualisé ce qui fait baisser le prix
d'accession au logement de 30 %. voilà
on cherche à innover à inventer pour que
chacun est accessible à la ville en cœur
de métropole et surtout qu'il soit euh
qu'il ait un toit et qu'il puisse vivre
dignement pour autant la bonne volonté
ne suffira
Jean-Philippe gar en appelle à l'État
notamment sur le respect de la loi et
ses rues et c'est 25 % de logements
sociaux dans les communes il y a urgence
à ce que l'État oblige toutes les
communes à participer à la solidarité
nationale et puis on manque évidemment
de manière criante de moyens le budget
de l'État l'aide à la pierre pour
construire des logements à des prix
abordables n'existe quasiment plus en
France parfois on construit encore du
logement social qui est trop cher ce qui
est une absurdité dont les loyers sont
trop chers parce que les moyens en
financement l'aide à la pierre ce qu'on
appelle l'aide à la pierre pour
construire n'est pas suffisant entre les
refus répétés de près par les banques et
les listes d'attentes pour les logements
sociaux qui s'allongent le maire de
Fontenet sbois craint une embolie
inévitable du secteur selon lui le
gouvernement n'a clairement pas pris la
mesure du problème voilà pour ce
reportage de Mathias Arz tir pentin je
me tourne d'abord vers vous pour faire
le constat c'est une crise du secteur du
logement qui dure depuis quelques années
qui s'accentue en 2023 et qui touche
plusieurs aspects vous avez raison la
crise elle touche tous les segments de
du logement le logement privé comme le
logement public sur les 12 derniers mois
glissant vous avez 35 % de permis de
construire en moins de signer pour faire
des logements vous avez mo-s 20 % de
mise en chantier concret par rapport à
des permis signés dans dans le passé et
dans les agences immobilières vous avez
moins 34 % de logement disponibl
proposés à nos concitoyens ça c'est pour
le parc privé et pour le parc public ou
parc social vous aurez sans doute à la
fin de l'année environ 82000 nouveaux
logements il faut remonter au début des
années 2000 pour avoir aussi peu de
logements sociaux nouveaux construits
dans notre pays ce qui veut dire que la
trombose elle est à la fois sur le parc
privé et sur le parc
donc c'est vraiment ce que plusieurs
ministres disent d'ailleurs et on les
rejoint une bombe sociale pour notre
pays et l'incapacité à nos concitoyens
de pouvoir s'inscrire dans un parcours
résidentiel Corine jolie vous êtes
d'accord cette crise du logement actuel
c'est une bombe
sociale alors oui complètement parce que
elle concerne à peu près tout le monde
je rejoins les chiffres qui ont été
évoqués c'est le marché locatif cette
année a été explosif on a eu moins
d'offres et plus de demandes c'est une
conséquence de la hausse des taux de
crédit c'est en fait les jeunes ne
pouvant plus acheter il restent
locataire du coup les nouveaux arrivants
sur la location n'ont pas du tout de
logement parce que les logements ne sont
pas libérés par leurs aînés les jeunes
ont donc du mal à acheter on a des taux
de crédit qui sont passé en un an et
demi de 1 % à là on est à 4,25 % donc
c'est une hausse vraiment brutale et les
les prix baisse un tout petit peu mais
ne compense pas du tout la capacité
d'emprunt elle a baissé de 25 % à peu
près et les prix ont baissé à l'échelle
nationale de 2 à 3 % donc c'est rien
donc ça bloque le marché ça a un impact
sur la location et puis je voudrais
quand même ajouter un point qui est à
mon avis très important dans cette crise
c'est les inégalités territoriales avec
vraiment des zones attractives qui sont
les métropoles et le littoral et des
zones à l'inverse qui ont qui luttent
pour avoir des habitants qui je pense à
certaines communes qui offrent des
vacances pour qu'on découvre que c'est
sympathique d'habiter là-bas et que pour
pousser les gens à ménager donc on a
aussi une vraie inégalité territoriale
ah oui cette crise du logement est
touche de manière différente nos
territoires pierreic on va évoquer avec
vous la question de Bordeaux une ville
qui elle pour le coup est attractive on
a envie d'y habiter mais est-ce que
l'offre de logement suit alors à
Bordeaux comme dans toutes les villes
comparables je pense il y a pas une
crise du logement il y a plusieurs
crises de logement qui et c'est la
difficulté que nous affrontons
actuellement ce télescope on l'a vu
crise de la production du logement
c'est-à-dire logement produit est de
plus en plus cher crise le foncier dans
nos villes il y a de moins en moins de
foncier donc il est de plus en plus il
est de plus en plus cher et également
cela ce télescope avec vous l'avez
évoqué vous avez raison le problème de
l'accès au crédit passer de 1 et5 % à
4,25 % en quelques mois effectivement ça
ne suscite pas des vocations pour pour
acheter et vous avez aussi quand on
parle de crise du logement il faut bien
spécifier c'est surtôt une crise du
logement abordable abordable et
notamment du logement social qui est en
crise dans nos villes on construit pas
assez logements social et nous les
maires nous héritons de souvent de
situations assez compliquées avec un peu
un désengagement de l'État à travers la
loi etlon et d'autres initiatives
législatives qui ont pas été très
heureus pour le logement social et donc
c'est à nous à trouver des outils pour
favoriser précisément davantage de
constructionement sociale ce qui est
important pour nous par exemple je vois
à Bordeaux c'est d'avoir augmenté le
seuil de déclenchement des opérations de
logement social je m'explique toute opé
toute opération à partir de 500 m² de
construction on a imposé l'obligation de
20 % d'accession sociale et toute
opération de 1000 m² on a imposé 40 %
tout à l'heure on parlait de 30 % ben
bordeau on est à 40 % de locatif social
imposés pour ces opérationsl parce que
on a un retard important à combler donc
politique volontariste et également un
dernier point il faut faire en sorte que
les loyers aussi ne ne suivent pas une
courbe inflationniste draisonnable comme
ça a été le cas dans beaucoup de villes
et nous Bordeaux nous avons réussi à
obtenir une expérimentation
l'encadrement des loyers on est un pays
qui a un trait jacobin un maire ne peut
pas décider d'une politique
d'encadrement des loyers sur son
territoire il doit demander à l'État
l'autorisation de l'expérimenter on par
on parlera tout à l'heure des solution
que les US peuvent mettre en place face
à cette crise du logement mais d'abord
un mot sur le constat ma ostegi et sur
l'exemple de Biaritz Biaritz c'est une
ville qui est très attractive une zone
touristique mais est-ce que les
habitants ne sont pas en train d'être un
petit peu chassé de cette ville avec les
prix de l'immobilier alors c'est un
phénomène qui a commencé déjà il y a il
y a assez longtemps et qui aujourd'hui
est devenu intenable euh puisque je en
plus des difficultés qui ont été
partagées par l'ensemble des personnes
présentes moi j'ai le phénomène de la
location saisonnière qu'on appelle la
location Airbnb qui a créé un mouvement
d'attractivité des investisseurs sont
venus ont acheté des logements euh
largement au-dessus du prix du marché
ont fait flamber le marché pour y faire
de laallocation saisonnière et nous
avons dû avec la communauté
d'agglomération enfin on reviendra
peut-être sur les solutions dû prendre
une mesure qui permet justement de
stopper de mettre un frein à cette
phénomène de location saisonnière j'ai
aussi euh très peu de très peu de de
propriétaires qui gardent enfin qui
mettent leur logement euh en en location
à l'année et ça aussi euh nous ne
cessons de demander de l'aide un lev
lier législatif un levier fiscal pour
que le le propriétaire qui fait de la
location saisonnière puisse passer en
location à l'année il n'y a aucun
intérêt aujourd'hui fiscalement il y
perd en plus s'il a un locataire qui ne
le règle pas il va mettre des mois voir
des années à se débarrasser du locataire
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
attractivité pour un propriétaire de
mettre du logement à l'année et moi j'ai
besoin de loger les jeunes j'ai
également besoin de loger les seniors
c'est-à-dire que j'ai des personnes en
général ce sont des femmes seules qui
ont des petites retraites qui sont resté
atire toute leur vie le propriétaire des
selles les enfants ne peuvent même plus
payer les les les droits de succession
parce que le le prix du logement a
explosé et donc ils revendent ce
logement ils expulsent la locataire que
je dois reloger dans un parc social qui
est bien en dessous je suis une ville
carencée j'ai donc l'obligation de faire
50 % de locatif enfin de de logements
sociaux nous le faisons avec beaucoup de
volontarisme nous sommes à peine à 11 %
de logement social sur la commune parce
que plus de 50 % de la commune de B est
inconstructible entre le couloir de
l'aéroport la loi littorale et les zones
Natura 2000 que nous avons donc notre
contrainte aujourd'hui c'est que nous
sommes la ville la plus dense du
département et nous n'avons plus de
foncier pour construire est-ce que
l'État fait assez pour justement
permettre aux habitants de Biaritz de se
loger et ne pas forcément développer les
locations touristiques saisonnières
alors je je veux pas charger les en
terme d'incitation mais mais très
franchement
aujourd'hui c'est c'est timide voire mou
alors on est reçu par les ministres on a
une écoute mais aujourd'hui moi je
demande des mesures fortes aujourd'hui
il n'y en a pas il y a la question de la
fiscalité que j'ai que j'ai soulevé et
comme l'a soulevé également madame la
question de la territorialité on ne peut
pas traiter une commune littorale
qu'elle soit basque ou bretonne comme on
traite la région parisienne ou comme on
traite la Corse donc moi aujourd'hui
j'ai besoin lorsqu'il y a un projet de
logement social en construction parce
que on le fait on est volontariste donc
sur nos dents creuses et bien il y a
comme dans toutes les villes des recours
moi j'ai besoin que l'État sur les
recours fassent que les recours soient
extrêmement courts pour que le projet
puisse voir jour et pouvoir loger mes
biarau tierur Repentin question
politique est-ce que cette situation
cette crise du logement actuel c'est le
bilan d'Emmanuel Macron depuis 6 ans ce
qui est clair c'est que la crise
certains l'ont annoncé il y a 4 ou 5 ans
en disant elle est devant nous au regard
d'un certain nombre de dispositions qui
sont pris à un moment donné le logement
quand vous prenez une décision vous
voyez les effets TR ou 4 ans après parce
que il faut mobiliser des terrains des
financements et donc aujourd'hui on
parle de crise il y a pas de décision ça
veut dire que la crise elle est devant
nous je suis obligé de de le dire
c'est-à-dire si on prend des décisions
maintenant elles n'auront des effets que
dans 2 ou 3 ans oui en 2017 quand vous
diminuez les APL qui est la ressource du
monde HLM et bien vous diminuez la
capacité de ces organismes à pouvoir
construire des logements nouveaux quand
vous supprimez la taxe de hitation qui
nous fait plaisir à individuellement à
chacun d'entre nous quand on on la paye
vous diminuez la ressource des
collectivités locales affecté au à la
construction quand vous dites que les
organismes HLM vont avoir une
exonération de foncier bâti pendant 25
ans vous êtes maire donc vous vous dites
à chaque fois je construis un bâtiment
de logement aujourd'hui je devrais
mettre en place des services qui me
coûteront plus cher que ce que me
rapporte le foncier bâti ou les
habitants qui sont dans le bâtiment donc
il faut revoir un certain nombre de
dispositifs car si chacun des maires
autour de cette table comme celui de
Fontenet a des spécificités
territoriales et il faut que nous ayons
les possibilités de pouvoir adapter ces
politiques à chacun de nos territoires
il y a quand même un modèle économique
global à revoir sur la question du
logement et notamment revenir sur une
aide au Mair qui bâtissent du logement
il faut donner la capacité par exemple à
des maires en zone tendue de pouvoir
plafonner les prix du foncier car
aujourd'hui on a une explosion des prix
du foncier pas le rendre obligatoire
mais si les maires veulent leur faire
dans leur territoire pouvoir le leur
donner cette capacité c'est répartir
aussi ce qu'on appelle la rente foncière
c'est-à-dire entre le propriétaire d'un
terrain qui est devenu constructible
quand il va le vendre la grande partie
de cette vente elle va dans les poches
du propriétaire alors même que c'est le
maire qui a donner cette richesse donc
je pense qu'il faut aussi répartir la
richesse entre la commune qui va devoir
assumer les services et le propriétaire
qui ne fait finalement que vendre grâce
au fait que son terrain a été rendu
constructible donc il faut revoir le
modèle économique du logement et y
compris revoir des sujets de fiscalité
pierre REMIC je vais citer le président
de la République Emmanuel Macron c'était
en mai dernier dans une interview au
magazine challenge et il décrivait le
système du logement et la politique en
faveur de ce secteur je le cite un
système de surdépense publiqu pour de l'
de l'inefficacité collective qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette vision du
logement d'Emmanuel Maron ben c'est un
diagnostic qui est très généraliste et
qui ne se vérifie pas sur le terrain ce
qui manque je pense à Emmanuel Macron
c'est d'avoir été élu de terrain d'avoir
été élu maire et d'être quotidiennement
je dis bien quotidiennement confronté à
nos concitoyens qui nous interroge sur
ce manque et sur cet enrichissement du
coûte du logement du logement dans nos
villes il faut que l'État intervienne de
façon plus efficace je suis d'accord il
y a peut-être des économies à faire mais
en tout cas il doit y avoir un souci
d'efficacit cité il faut que l'État
encourage les maires bâtisseurs vous
l'avez évoqué mais je crois que c'est et
pour le moment c'est pas le cas nous ne
sommes pas du tout encouragé à explorer
davantage les possibilités que nous
avons sur le terrain avec il suffit pas
de construire quand vous construisez
vous avez pour un maire après tous les
services publics municipaux qui vont
avec donc cela mérite de la part de
l'état des encouragements que nous ne
voyons pas venir aujourd'hui Corine
jolie dans cette crise est-ce qu'il faut
encadrer certains prix titin parlait de
l'encadrement des prix du foncier
pierreic de l'encadrement des loyers
vous quelle est votre vision est-ce que
ça peut ça peut aider alors je vais
juste commencer par rajouter un problème
à tout ce qui a été dit parce que on
parle beaucoup des actions politiques et
il y a un point qu'on qu'on n pas encore
abordé et qui pourtant va avoir un
impact c'est tous les enjeux écologiques
euh puisqueen fait là on a parlé d'un
certain nombre de contraintes les
propriétaires actuellement font face à
la contraintte notamment les logements F
et G qu'on appelle les passoirs
thermiques doivent être rénommés d'ici
2025 ou d'ici
2028 2025 pour les logements g 2028 pour
les logements F sinon ils seront
interdits à la location avec tout ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer ça va s'ajouter on
a déjà les crédits qu'on monté on a des
logements qui vont sortir du parc s'ils
n'ont pas été rénové sauf que en
discutant avec n'importe quel acteur du
bâtiment vous verrez que c'est
impossible de mener toutes ces
rénovation dans les temps on parle de 5
millions de rénovation à faire pour dans
5 ans donc 1 million par an il y a même
pas la main d'œuvre pour le faire donc
j'ai l'impression que le logement est
une sorte de secteur qu'on compresse de
tous les côtés en en rajoutant un peu
des contraintes dans tous les sens mais
en ne fournissant aucune solution aux
acteurs de terrain pour finalement
atteindre leurs objectifs et régler les
problème qu'on leur soumet je rejoins
assez le problème de de manque de
terrain de Monsieur Macron parce que
c'est vrai qu'il est fréquent que les
solutions ne semblent juste pas réaliste
et vous vous dites attention à ne pas
mettre trop de contrainte dans le
secteur du logement alors en tout cas
sur précisément le point du logement
social les maires en tout cas de
nombreux maires ont une contrainte un
objectif défini par la loi SRU qui
impose aux communes de construire entre
20 % et 25 % de logements sociaux sur
leur territoire et actuellement et bien
si communes sur 10 ne respecte pas la
loi SRU on va écouter la réaction du
président de la MF David lissnard sur ce
point il faut faire très attention aux
sentences morales quand vous n'avez pas
de fon c'est des chiffres pas de la
morale si parce que dans le discours
c'est dire regardez ces maires qui
veulent pas appliquer méchant il
faudrait pas loger les gens c'est c'est
c'est tout à fait différent c'est-àdire
que dans dans certains cas ça peut
arriver mais dans beaucoup de cas c'est
parce que le foncier est devenu très
rare et d'ailleurs toutes les mesures
qui ont été prises depuis 20 ans dans la
loi élan la loi allure les lois du flot
la loi climat et résilience avec le zéro
artificialisation nette rarifil foncier
que l'on peut édifier donc
surenchérissent le coup du foncier donc
font que les bailleurs sociaux eux-mêmes
qui ont été affaiblis par différentes
mesures de depuis ces dernières années
de budgétaire et bien n'arrivent plus
eux-mêmes à construire maidar rostegi
ces chiffres et ces communes qui
n'arrivent pas à atteindre cet objectif
de la loi SRU est-ce que ça veut dire
que certaines communes ne jouent pas le
jeu il est possible que certaines
commune ne joue pas le jeu moi je je ne
peux parler que de ce que je connais
c'est-à-dire de la mienne et de celle
des des 155 autres communes qui compose
la communauté d'agglomération
Pays-Basque il y a une véritable volonté
de de ma part de celle de de mon équipe
municipale et de l'ensemble des
collègues de faire du logement dis
social la preuve c'est que depuis que
nous avons été élus en 2020 nous avons
transformé une auberge de jeunesse qui
était vieillissante et qui ne
fonctionnait plus nous l'avons vendu à
un bailleur social qui va la transformer
en logement pour des saisonniers parce
que nous n'avons plus personne pour
venir travailler dans nos hôtels nos
restaurants donc des saisonniers
également des étudiants et nous sommes
actuellement sur la construction d'un
très grand quartier qui s'appelle
Aguilera qui est déjà notre pleain
sportive où nous avons notre club de
rugby notre historique club de tennis et
le challenge est de rendre ces terrains
constructiblees ils ne le sont pas et
donc nous sommes en processus de mecdu
qui est rendre les terrains
constructibles j'ai essayé de le faire
de la façon la plus partagée possible
avec les habitants on va en être à 3 ans
de processus administratif pour rendre
ces terrains constructibles et avec
j'imagine une fois que ça sera fait des
recours de tous les côtés et là à la clé
on a entre 250 et 300 logements dont
j'ai un besoin absolu est-ce que
aujourd'hui l'État va tenir compte de
cette volonté que nous avons et que nous
sommes en train de concrétiser lorsque
je vois le montant de la pénalité SRU je
pense que non et donc c'est vécu comme
une injustice c'est-à-dire qu'on fait on
se démène contre V et Maré parce que le
mot social fait peur peut-être qu'un
jour il faudra appeler ses logements
autrement que des logements sociaux mais
des logements pour tous puisque nos
classes moyennes sont entrées avec les
deux pieds dedans et donc aujourd'hui il
faut que l'État on demande pas des pass
droit on demande pas de la bienveillance
on demande simplement du pragmatisme et
j'attends beaucoup du nouveau ministre
du Logement qui est un maire qui est un
l'ancien maire de duncarc voilà parce
que lui effectivement a cette
connaissance du terrain et lui peut-être
saura mieux comprendre nos difficultés
et trouver les solutions les plus
adaptées à nos territoires qui sont si
différents tir pentin est-ce qu'il faut
renforcer les obligations des communes
en matière de construction de logement
social ou alors assouplir certaines
normes qui les empêchent de construire
ces logements alors moi je vais pas
faire de la langue de bois et je veux
dire qu'effectivement un certain nombre
de maires ne souhaitent pas sur leur
territoire réaliser
des opérations de logement social y
compris pour des raisons électorales et
s'en font parfois la publicité dans leur
publication municipal mais je ne veux
pas dire que c'est l'ensemble des maires
il y a une partie et hélas on parle
souvent de ces maires qui si siamment ne
veulent pas le faire alors que beaucoup
d'autres font des efforts pour rattraper
ce retard et c'est un objectif de la loi
qui date depuis 2000 il y a 22 ans que
cette loi a été votée et d'une façon
générale beaucoup d'efforts sont fait
par les collectivités locales et
d'ailleurs le président Lisnard dans la
même interview dit il faut respecter la
loi chacun peut ensuite mettre des
dispositions sur son territoire par
rapport à des outils le maire de
Bordeaux dit par exemple à partir de
temps de logement j'impose 40 % de
logements sociaux d'autres interviennent
en mettant à disposition des des
terrains d'autres vont à la chasse au
logement vacant car nous avons 8 % de
logement vacant dans le parc privé ils
peuvent être par le biaet d'association
notamment venir dans le champ social à
travers des associations qui louent au
prix du logement à Chalem et ça rentre
dans la comptabilisation ce que je veux
dire par ces exemple c'est qu'il n'y a
pas une solution à la crise du logement
dans notre pays il faut agir sur tous
les segments de la maîtrise du foncier
jusqu'à l'acte de construire dans le
parc privé comme dans le parc social il
y a pas une solution la boîte à outil
malheureusement elle a été vidée et je
voudrais attirer l'attention de celles
et ceux qui nous écoutent élus de faire
attention au projet dit de
décentralisation de la politique du
logement dont on parle beaucoup moi je
suis assez inquiet de savoir pourquoi on
veut absolument décentraliser cette
politique qui est aujourd'hui en crise
décentraliser une politique qui n'a plus
de moyens mettra les maires en première
ligne sans avoir la possibilité de
résoudre la crise qu'attendent de nos
concitoyens pierre RIC on le voit il y a
des solutions hein pour construire du
logement social mais il y a aussi
certains freins et les maires dans
certain certaines communes sont un petit
peu en fronde contre l'une des normes
qui a été ajouté par la loi climat et
résilience l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation net des sols en 2050
est-ce que cette norme elle l'empêche de
construire non c'est pas forcément une
contrainte nous nous étions imposé nous
même cette contrainte avant même avant
même la loi résilience en disant la
richesse d'une ville d'une commune c'est
également de réserver ces derniers
espaces de nature c'est bien de faire
venir des habitants mais si les
habitants n'ont plus des espace de
respiration de nature préservée dans la
ville à mon avis on passe à côté d'un
d'un impératif donc je pense que c'est
un atout pour une ville de faire du Zéro
artificialisation mais par contre ce que
ça vous impose c'est de faire ce que
l'on appelle nous à Bordeaux c'est de
construire la ville sur la ville
c'est-à-dire de construire sur des
endroits déjà artificialisés déjà
urbanisés de systématiquement préférer
la rénovation plutôt que la démolition
et la construction neuve donc
effectivement ça complique notre travail
mais je pense c'est un impératif que de
garder cette notion de zéro
artificialisation même si nos réserves
sont plus faible il faut en trouver de
nouvelles il faut construire en hauteur
faut pas avoir peur de construire en
hauteur faut pas avoir peur de densifier
certains quartiers donc ce sont des
obligations nouvelles mais à mon avis il
faut surtout pas transiger sur ce zéro
artificialisation ma arostegi qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette objectif
écologique de non artificialisation
est-ce qu'il faut l'assouplir c'est une
contrainte alors sur ma commune
égoïstement je je suis peu concerné même
si effectivement j'ai racheté un terrain
qui qui devait être urbanisé pour en
faire une ferme urbaine et pédagogique
mais lorsque je vois mes collègues de du
de l'agglomération Pays-Basque eux n'ont
pas ce cette même vision parce qu'on a
besoin aussi de foncier pour faire du
développement économique et ça c'est ça
c'est un point par rapport à ce que
vient de dire pierre urmic il va falloir
éduquer nos population à accepté de
construire en hauteur parce que ça ça
passe pas du tout donc moi je veux bien
faire du R+ 5 6 7 comme on a fait dans
les années 70 mais le citoyen des années
2020 ça ilaccepte pas donc on est en
fait dans un étau entre des besoins de
développement économique sur certains
territoires préserver le foncier
agricole préserver la qualité du cadre
de vie et en même temps amener le
citoyen à faire ce qu'on fait nous à
biarite c'est-à-dire faire de la ville
sur la ville oui Corine jolie résoudre
cette crise du logement c'est aussi
tenir compte et bien du marché des
attentes des particuliers sur leur
vision de l'urbanisme alors oui le
problème c'est que la plupart de ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer n'est pas très
populaire construire en hauteur ce n'est
pas très populaire les logements sociaux
ce n'est pas très populaire c'estàd
qu'on sait qu'il y a toujours une
opposition locale assez forte sur ce
genre de projet qui se enfin le logement
social si vous regardez des cartes de
prix au mè Carr on voit bien que là où
il y a le plus de logements sociaux bah
ça fait baisser les prix de l'immobilier
donc les propriétaires qui habitent à
côté quand il voi arriver des logements
sociaux ou quand il voi arriver quand
vous êtes dans une secteur de maison et
que vous commencez à construire du
collectif ça fait baisser les prix donc
les propriétaires ils ont une opposition
on peut pas réellement s'attendre à
mieux et s'opposer bah voilà ce sont vos
ce sont vos élus donc c'est c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué pour les maires de
gérer cette opposition et que s'il n'y a
pas on va dire une explication
collective des objectifs partagés euh
c'est normal d'avoir des procédures qui
durent des années parce que localement
personne ne veut des logements sociaux
ou des immeubles tir pentin je voudrais
qu'on finisse ces échanges en évoquant
les solutions qui sont proposées par le
gouvernement la semaine dernière
àuncerque la première ministre a évoqué
une aide de l'État pour mettre sur le
marché 15000 logements locatifs
intermédiaires supplémentaires une aide
également publique pour 35000 logements
étudiants d'ici à 2026 et puis une aide
pour les promoteurs pour leur acheter
47000 logements neufs est-ce que c'est
suffisant vous parlez en dizaines de
milliers de logements quand la demande
est en millions de logements il y a donc
un gap entre l'annonce qui est faite et
les besoins de nos concitoyens moi je
voudrais dire qu'il y a eu un travail
considérable qui a été mené au titre du
CNR Conseil national de la refondation
de la fondation abépierre jusqu'à la au
promoteurs immobiliers qui ont tous
proposer un socle de proposition commune
il faut que l'État regarde ces
propositions elles font consensus il y a
un certain nombre de dispositions dont
je vous ai parlé il faut revenir à la
table financière pour aider les
organismes de logements sociaux qui
n'ont plus de sous en poche et donc qui
ne pourront pas construire il faut aider
les maires qui accepte du logement sur
leur territoire qu'il soit social
intermédiaire ou privé toute la chaîne
du logement est aujourd'hui grippé et
puis vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens il
faut aussi leur donner un discours de
responsabilité il faut réhabiliter
l'acte de construire car un certain
nombre de dispositions législatives ont
été adoptées au cours des dernières Ann
années tourner vers l'environnement
c'est nécessaire ne plus construire
comme on le faisait auparavant mais ça
s'est traduit dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens comme l'acte de construire
devait être combattu et c'est vrai que
quand on est maire aujourd'hui on a plus
de difficultés à faire sortir un
bâtiment que c'était le cas il y a
quelques années il faut redire à nos
concitoyens qu'il faut construire pour
leur ger leurs enfants pour leur donner
les mêmes chances finalement qu'ils ont
eu eux quand ils se sont émancipés
qu'ils ont quitté le domicile familial
pour avoir une trajectoire de vie donc
réhabiliter l'acte de construire
pierreic pour conclure il nous reste une
minute s'il y avait un message à envoyer
à l'état envoyer au gouvernement c'est
de mettre plus de moyens public pour
relancer le logement engagez-vous j'ai
envie de leur dire je pense que le
ministre du Logement ça a été dit est un
ancien maire donc je prends ça comme un
homme un homme de terrain avec une
écoute en tout cas vis-à-vis de nos
problématiques également vis-à-vis de
nos populations accréditer l'idée que on
peut construire sans bétonner on a eu
des mes bétonneurs je pense cette époque
là est fini là aujourd'hui il y a y
compris des nouveaux matériaux des
matériaux biosourcés on peut construire
bois c'est-à-dire des matériaux plus
doux que le tout béton qu'on a connu ces
dernières années donc il faut continuer
à construire pas seulement dans nos
grandes villes il faut construire aussi
dans les villes moyennes je pense que il
faut que l'État s'il faut faire une
proposition et enfin une vraie politique
d'aménagement du territoire et
d'équilibre des territoires en fonction
en répartissant les grands centres
urbains les villes les villes moyennes
je pense un challenge la
décentralisation oui malgré des effets
pervers mais surtout une politique
nationale d'aménagement du territoire de
rééquilibre des constructions merci à
tous les quat d'avoir participé à ce
débat sur la crise du logement dans un
instant je vais recevoir sur ce sur ce
plateau le président du Sénat Gerard
Larché pour évoquer les enjeux de ce
congrès des maires de France et juste
avant on va écouter le président de la
MF David lissnard justement sur ses
préoccupations pour les maires au
quotidien de quel état d'esprit dans
quel état d'esprit vous abordez ce
congrès bien nous l'abordons avec que la
volonté de faire en sorte que la
République française ne soit pas une
abstraction que nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants puisse vivre dans un pays
qui rejette toute forme d'exclusion de
l'autre à priori toute forme
d'antisémitisme de racisme toute
violence bref je crois que nous
ressentons bien que nous sommes à une
époque particulièrement grave et face à
cette époque dans cette époque de ce
contexte le pouvoir local est une des
solutions alors et d'ailleurs je je veux
dire je veux dire je veux remercier je
veux vous remercier de de de votre
présence remercier Christophe Béchu le
ministre notre ministre dire de tutelle
c'est un mot qu'on qu'on a'aime pas mais
le ministre qui nous accompagne au
quotidien avec qui on bosse
et dire que ce congrès ça va être le
Congrès des alertes le Congrès parfois
des dénonciations mais aussi le Congrès
des solutions et ça nous y tenons
absolument avec 15 ministres qui vont
participer à nos travaux la première
ministre qui sera présente une
interaction avec l'exécutif on veut
stimuler stimuler la République
française voilà pour ces mots de David
Lisnard le président de l'AMF c'était
hier dans l'ouverture de ce congrès et
ce matin j'accueille sur ce plateau
Gérard Larcher bonjour le président du
Sénat bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes aujourd'hui
en visite au Congrès des Maires de
France une visite j'allais dire
naturelle he puisqu'on le rappelle le
Sénat et la chambre du Parlement qui
représent les collectivités
territoriales on va évoquer les enjeux
de ce congrès des maires de France avec
d'abord un chiffres jardarcher depuis
les élections municipales 2020 en
moyenne chaque mois 40 maires remettent
et bien remettent leur écharpe tricolor
démissionne est-ce que vous craignez
véritablement une crise des vocations
d'abord c'est vrai le Sénat a la
vocation constitutionnel de représenter
les collectivités territoriales de la
République et à travers de ce réseau de
500000 élus
territoriaux qui sont notre
légitimité ce sont aussi les citoyens
qui vivent dans ses collectivités
territoriales voilà pourquoi notre rôle
est certes de représenter les
collectivités territoriales mais aussi
d'être à l'écoute de l'ensemble du pays
vous disiez il y a un instant
euh jamais le nombre de mères qui ont
démissionné mais je allais dire jamais
autant de conseillers municipaux qui ont
jeté l'éponge euh à mi
mandat j'étais il y a 2 semaines dans
l'avyon et le préfet faisait une
comparaison entre le précédent mandat
municipal et et celui en cours il avait
en 3 ans autant de démission de maire
qu'il n'avait eu en 6 ans son
prédécesseur je crois qu'il a une forme
de crise d'évocation mais qui est lié au
thème du
congrès de l'an dernier est-ce que
aujourd'hui les maires et leur conseil
municipal ont encore la capacité à agir
souvenez-vous c'était le titre pouvoir
agir nous avons perdu en 15 ans
levier fiscaux et financiers il reste en
tout et pour tout au maire le foncier
bâti nous avons un état qui n'est plus
accompagnateur les préfets ont perdu
l'autorité sur la plupart des services
de l'État et nous avons un état qui est
devenu
senseur la complexification la réalité
d'un code de l'urbanisme qui appr pris
en disant 40 % et je vous parle pas du
Code Général des Collectivités
aujourd'hui un maire peut plus faire un
pu plui sans avoir des injonctions
contradictoires de la dral de la DRAC
d'agence de l'État et cette réalité là
ça décourage s'y ajoute le climat de
violence et ça nous renvoie au congrès
de cette année commune attaquée
République menacée parce que ces 500000
élus c'est le ciment de la République et
justement parmi les causes de ces
démission il y a la hausse des violences
contre les élus le gouvernement a lancé
un un plan national de lutte contre ces
violences le Sénat a également voté dans
une proposition de loi un durcissement
des peines pour les auteurs de ces
violences contre les élus quand on fait
le diagnostic qu'est-ce qui a pêché dans
la protection de nos élus locaux écoutez
je crois qu'on a pris conscience de
cette
insuffisance c'était au moment de la
mort dramatique du maire de signe il
s'est déroulé dans le Var en 2019
presque 4 années depuis nous avons dans
un certain nombre de textes je pense
engagement et proximité je pense 3DS
pris un certain nombre de mesures nous
avons eu des propositions de loi mais là
le 10 octobre nous avons voté nous avons
voté à la quasi unanimité au Sénat le
renforcement de la pénalisation des
violences qu'elle soit physique qu'elle
soit verbale qu'elle soit sur les
réseaux pour protéger les élus nous
voyons qu'au fond ça ne suffira pas dans
une société
fracturé fracturé divisé faut all c'est
le retour de l'autorité dont nous avons
besoin on l'a vu dans les près de 600
communes qui ont connu des émeutes à la
fin du mois de juin et on voit que ceux
qui ont été en première ligne encore une
fois comme dans la crise sanitaire comme
dans la crise des gilets jaunes ça a été
les maires les maires qui ont fait face
à ces réalités à cette violence les
maires ils ont besoin eux qui sont
quelque part les remparts de la
démocratie ils ont besoin du rempart de
la République et c'est ça notre respons
vous dites ça ne suffira pas il faut
restaurer l'autorité des maires il faut
des mesures supplémentaires par exemple
augmenter les prérogatives des polices
municipales c'est un des sujets qui qui
est sur la table nous avons une
commission d'enquête qui est en train de
travailler à la commission des lois sur
la suite des émeutes je crois que les
mesures qui ont été annoncées elles
peuvent être intéressantes elles sont
insuffisantes il faut réfléchir sur le
fond sur la cause il y a des sujets par
exemple majeur le logement est-ce qu'on
continue à ce que le le logement soit en
quelque sorte sorti du pouvoir
d'appréciation des maires aujourd'hui
dans une commission d'attribution le
maire pardonnez-moi c'est le passager
clandestin de l'attribution des
logements nous avons voté début octobre
une proposition de loi de Sophie prima
pour dire que ça n'était plus possible
que nous ayons cette politique de
logement parce que le maire il est le
garant de la cohésion sociale dans sa
commune voilà un premier exemple que je
peux donner très directement et
justement sur ce pouvoir du maire on va
parler des relations entre l'État et nos
communes une première question sur le
fait que cette année le président de la
République ne vient pas au Congrès des
maire est-ce que c'est un mauvais
signuvais signal qui eny moi je pense
que ici vous êtes quelque part dans une
référence au cœur de la
démocratie la démocratie c'est d'abord
la démocratie locale et ça se vit dans
la diversité de nos conseils municipaux
moi personnellement c'est pas un
rendez-vous obligatoire pour personne
mais c'est un rendez-vous peut-être ou
puiser une forme de renouveau de sa
légitimité il lui appartient de prendre
ses décisions ce que je sais c'est que
les maires ils ont besoin du rempart de
la République et le Sénat comme une
institution a vraiment ça j'allais dire
pas simplement dans ses gênnes dans son
attitude quotidienne voilà pourquoi nous
travaillons actuellement au-delà des
annonces parce que David lissnard a
raison à de dire on fait beaucoup
d'annonces avant congrès et puis après
congrès il se passe plus grand-chose je
vais prendre un exemple
septembre 2022 le président de la
République nous annonce une grande loi
de décentralisation il le fait devant le
président des maires le président des
départements la présidente des régions
ça fait 14 mois il s'est rien passé et
on nous annonce c'est plutôt sympathique
que Eric ve chargé d'une mission
pour j'ai dit à Saint-Denis qu'on avait
tout sur étagère le rapport du Sénat du
6 juillet dernier qui est le fruit
d'ailleurs de l'initiative du Président
de la République mais qui n'a été suivi
d'aucune conséquence donc je le dis
clairement il y a urgence à agir j'ai
parfois le sentiment du côté de
l'exécutif et du président de la
République il y aurait urgence à
attendre pour la décentralisation et
bien nous déposerons des propositions de
loi dans les semaines qui viennent alors
on le rappelle la décentralisation c'est
quand l'État central donne plus de
liberté d'action plus de pouvoir aux
collectivités locales concrètement vous
en tant que président du Sénat qu'est-ce
que vous proposez pour réussir cette
décentralisation pas de suppression
d'une strate de collectivité locale
pardonnez-moi c'est le genre de débat
que nous avons eu et qui ne mène à rien
vous savez il y a un couple très
important ce qui s'appelle le couple
maire préfet ça veut dire qu'il faut un
état territorial fort ne croyez pas qu'à
décentralisation forte il ne faillent
pas un état territorial fort aujourd'hui
les préfets n'ont plus d'autorité sur la
plupart des services de l'État et aller
voir les couloirs d'une sous-préfecture
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'était il y a 20
ans et vous verrez que l'État n'est plus
l'accompagnateur le conseiller mais
comme il n'a plus de pouvoir il devient
le censeur c'est un premier sujet il y a
des sujets comme l'urbanistme ou les
demandes qui sont faites aux élus pas
simplement du fait de la
complexification sont
schizophréniques entre la loi et ses
rues d'un côté le zan de
l'autre les la ZFE 3e comment
voulez-vous que les élus aujourd'hui
faire un PLU ou un plui pour un maire
moi j'ai été maire TR décennies j'ai
connu le temps de la liberté pour les
élus je vois mon ma successeur qui est
une femme exceptionnelle à rambouillé
bien la compleité trop de contraint trop
de normes quiatt sur les pardonnez-moi
nous sommes paralysés et nous sommes
face à une crise du logement vous venez
d'en parler dans la précédente table
ronde et ben je vais vous dire on s'en
sortira que si on redonne de la liberté
de l'initiative au ma pour reconnecter
justement ces territoires avec le
pouvoir central est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à un retour du cumu des
mandats écoutez je pense que le lien
entre un mandat exécutif local et le
lien parement est une nécessité chez
nous c'est une réflexion que nous allons
avoir pour
clore notre groupe de travail
institutionnel parce que le Président de
la République s'était aussi engagé au
moment de l'élection présidentielle à
mettre en place un groupe
transpartisan comme ça venait pas nous
l'avons mis en place en novembre 2022
nous rendrons notre rapport en février
je pense qu'il est utile ce lien entre
un mandat exécutif local et un mandat
parlementaire je crois que ça a été une
fausse bonne idée que d'interdire au
parlementaires d'avoir un mandat
exécutif local et puis dans ce contexte
de crise de confiance des maires un
maire sur de demande une augmentation de
l'indemnité de maire vous êtes
favorable cette ha de l'indemnité quand
le maire exerce au nom de l'État il faut
quand même qu'à un moment on se dise que
ça peut pas être simplement la
collectivité locale qui reconnaît ça
mais au-delà de l'indemnité B je
rappelle qu'elle ne doit pas être ajusté
unique pour les communes de plus de 3500
habitants qu'elle doit être pour tous
les maires une indemnité qui est
revisité qui prenne en compte son rôle
son rôle notamment de représentant de
l'État il faut aussi se poser la
question de la vie professionnelle du
maire et de la conjugaison entre vie
professionnelle et fonction d'élu
certains disent faut en faire un métier
je pense qu'il faut trouver l'équilibre
entre les deux et puis quand on a été
maire de mandats TR mandats est-ce qu'il
y a pas c'est un ancien ministre du
Travail qui vous dit ça à reconnaître la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
parce que je pense qu'avoir été maire
c'est une expérience à nul autre pareil
moi personnellement je puise dans mon
expérience de maire C mandats quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel dans la
réaction du quotidien donc je vous
réponds très clairement que le groupe de
travail devrait rendre un rapport qui
sera pl ôt favorable il y a un débat euh
un cumulle un cumul qui soit cadré qui
soit limité mais pardonnez-moi j'ai été
président du Sénat et ma en même temps
j'ai eu l'impression de remplir mes deux
fonctions d'une manière qui ne m'avait
pas conduit à tellement de critiques
puisqu'il m'avait réélu on va finir cet
entretien Jard Larché par en évoquant
deux sujets d'actualité d'abord la
guerre en Israël et en Palestine un
accord a été conclu entre Israël et le
Hamas pour une trêve de 4 jours et la
libération de 50 Otages est-ce que vous
avez la confirmation qu'il aura des age
français parmi eux écoutez soyons très
très prudent sur ce sur ce
sujet n'oublions pas la Genèse
l'agression d'une une organisation
terroriste qui tue
1400 civils israéliens et naturellement
un enchaînement d'un droit légitime d'un
pays à se défendre avec les conséquences
qu'on connaît toute reprise de
discussion qui permettent quelque part
de libérer des otages d'avoir un temps
pour permettre aux civils
d'évacuer les théâtres de guerre est un
élément positif et puis se poser la
question de quelle solution demain dans
cette partie du Proche Orient c'est un
sujet sur lequel je suis personnellement
assez engagé à un moment plus personne
n'y croyait je pense à la suite des
accords d'Abraham je continue à prender
une solution à deux états accord
d'Abraham entre Israël et certains pays
arabes et dans un dialogue naturellement
parce que il y a un droit d'Israël à
exister reconnu depuis 1948 et il y a un
droit aux citoyens israéliens d'exercer
librement leurs citoyené solution à deux
états est-ce qu'il faut un cesser le feu
après cette trêve de 4 jours écoutez
chaque chose en son temps chaque chose
en son temps la réalité c'est qu' reste
derrière 50 Otages il en restera 190 et
que la réalité c'est c'est tous les
otages qu'il faut libérer c'est tous les
otages j'allais dire sans distinction ni
de nationalité ni
d'âge dernier sujet d'actualité gerérard
Larcher l'affaire Joel garot le sénateur
de Loire Atlantique a été mise en examen
car il est accusé d'avoir drogué la
députée Sandrine joso afin je cite de
commettre un viol ou une agression
sexuelle vous lui avez demandé dans un
courrier de prendre ses responsabilités
et de se mettre en retrait de ce mandat
de son mandat de sénateur et de
démissionner de s fonctions de
secrétaire du Sénat et de vice-président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
est-ce qu'il vous a répondu écoutez
d'abord je voudrais rappeler que c'est
euégard à la gravité des faits et à la
dignité de la fonction de parlementaire
et qu'au n de ça j'ai jugé qu'il était
de mon devoir de demander à ce
parlementaire de démissionner de
démissionner de deux fonctions éminentes
au Sénat secrétaire du bureau du Sénat
et Vice-Présidente de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées je lui ai demandé de se
mettre en retrait mais je m'applique un
principe tant qu'il n'y a pas eu de
décision de justice il y a la
présomption d'innocence la deuxième des
choses c'est que le Sénat collabore
pleinement à l'enquête qui est conduite
et je rappelle que seule la justice peut
démettre de son mandat un parlementaire
mais je vous dis la question de
l'éthique et de la déontologie est pour
moi essentiel voilà pourquoi j'ai
demandé à ce
sénateurz pas rép de écoutez il m'a fait
une lettre je la transmettrai dans le
cadre de l'enquête à qui de droit et si
jamais il refuse de démissionner du
bureau du Sénat est-ce que vous lu
contraindrez la même chose protection du
mandat je pense qu'il est entré dans une
phase de réflexion personnelle qui
pourrait répondre au principe que
j'exige
déontologie et éthique de la part des
parlementaires et sans faiblesse donc
cette réponse de Joel gario vous allez
la transmettre aux enquêteurs à quiis de
droit c'estàd c'est ma responsabilité
j'assumerai mes responsabilité pour ceux
qui me connaissent j'ai plutôt
l'habitude de les assumer merci beaucoup
jarard Larcher d'être venu sur le
plateau de Public Sénat pour notamment
évoquer les enjeux de ce 105e congrès
des maires de France on va finir cette
émission par voir des temps forts d'une
table ronde qui a été organisé ici au
Parc des Expositions de la Porte de
versaill sur l'engagement de l' de l'élu
local vous allez voir un engagement qui
est toujours plus exigeant Karim boamran
saintouin 52000 habitants saine
Saint-Denis comment vous entendez les
les enseignements de de de cette enquête
auprès de de vos collègues élus et par
rapport à la réalité qui est la vôtre et
celle de votre équipe municipale 60000
habitants à saint-toin je je peux que
souscrire à ce qui a été dit à un moment
où on est en pleine crise politique
idéologique écologique sociale on a
jamais eu autant besoin d'un maire d'une
maire et paradoxalement on a jamais eu
aussi peu de moyens et la fonction de
maire a jamais été aussi précarisée sur
le plan social ça a été évoqué lors de
la présentation de l'étude de Monsieur
fouco que sur le plan judiciaire
juridique protection juridique on
l'évoqué tout à l'heure où lorsqu'on a
des plaintes ou des attaques peu de m
ont l'impression d'être soutenu mais sur
le plan matériel sur le plan pécuniaire
mais aussi sur le plan institutionnel et
aussi sur le sur le plan
psychosociologique c'està-dire la
gestion de la la la carrière post post
mer aujourd'hui le le le sujet qu'on a
et la réflexion que je voulais partager
avec vous chers collègues chers amis
c'est je me tourne parce que je
regardais la présence de Monsieur ver
ancien maire de de Ch chanti qu'on
entendra tout à l'heure bonjour et et je
m'en réjouis mais le sujet c'est quelle
que soit l'appartenance partisane peut
sont les ministres qui ont un ancrage
territorial et par voie de conséquence
peu sont les maires qui ont la
possibilité d'avoir une oreille
attentive complice sur la fonction de
maire aujourd'hui au-delà de ce qui a
été décrit par Monsieur foucco au-delà
des témoignage au-delà de on va dire de
l'espoir partagé qu'on peut porter tous
collectivement parce que si nous sommes
ici aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous
croyons encore en la fonction du maire
en la fonction de la République en la
fonction de nos valeurs que que que nous
partageons tous collectivement c'est une
inquiétude vraiment une inquiétude que
j'ai en tant que maire sur la
pérénisation de cette fonction pour les
prochaines années moi j'aimerais bien
voir la prochaines études en 2026 sur le
nombre de maires qui décid de repartir
le nombre d'élus d'équipe municipale qui
décid de repartir parce que il y a vous
avez eu des démissions dans dans votre
équipe municipale depuis les dernières
élections j'ai eu aucune démission dans
dans ma majorité c'est une majorité qui
tient bien mais je voudrais pas au-delà
de du retour d'expérience locale au
locale qui n'est pas vraiment
significatif de ce qui se passe pour les
36000 maires nous à Saint-Ouin ça se
passe très bien on a énormément de
projets structurants que ce soit
l'Académie Tony Parker que ce soit un
complexe hospitalier de 12000 étudiants
que ce soit les Jeux Olympiques que ce
soit l'arrivée de la DGSI on est entre
guillemets un village quand on a des
projets d'urbanisme souvent on a des
recours c'est compliqué oui alors
justement le sujet c'est que nous on est
pardonnez-moi de l'anglicisme on est
staffé en conséquence mais quand je
discute avec mes collègues a des équipes
a des jur on ce qu' faut en
revanche nous c'est l'AR qui cache la
forêt quand vous discuz avec je me je me
promène souvent en région et quand je
discute avec des des collègues Mair on
voit bien les problématiques qui sont
décrites à savoir manque de moyens
humains et on l'a vu dans l'extrait du
film de Michel Tavares un poids un poids
juridique un une responsabilité qui fait
que cette charge mentale est pesante et
j'ai même envie de dire à terme assez
destructrice pour les les maires qui qui
décide de de dééposer cette fonction un
point qui a été intéressant sur la
aspect retraite je partage totalement ce
qui a été dit que je partage ou pas à la
limite c'est pas ça le sujet c'est
scientifique mais en tout cas c'est
assez révélateur d'un élément la
majorité des mères et c'est ça qui est
frustrant c'est que on voit vraiment le
yatus qu'il y a entre l'image qu'on
pourrait avoir en disons c'est la shérif
ou le shérif avec une hyper puissance
avec un hyper pouvoir qui effectivement
est déconnecté de tout problème
financiers de tout problème de retraite
de tout problème juridique et qui grâce
à un coup de téléphone peut tout régler
et la réalité génère une véritable
frustration et une véritable inquiétude
à moyen et long terme pour toute une
génération de M et là où on doit sonner
la sonnette d'alarme et je félicite tout
le travail qui a été fait par la MF
c'est que si jamais derrière on croit en
pacte au pacte républicain si derrière
on croit la fonction de maire si derriè
on croit au niveau des institutions et
ça a été évoqué par ma collègue maire
d'Alby il faut vraiment que une bonne
partie de l'establishment prenneent
conscience que il y a un risque que
notre système républicain soit délité
parce que il va y avoir un des
engagements de plus en plus progressif
de toute une génération sur la question
des élus locaux donc des freins à lever
effectivement et la nécessité de de de
sécuriser l'action des des mères je vous
rappelle qu'il y a des des points micro
dans les les allées vous pouvez
intervenir c'est votre congrès et on ne
monopolise pas la parole sur la la scène
bien évidemment en fonction des réalités
que vous vivez dans vos communes des
réactions que vous avez aux
enseignements de l'enquête mais aussi
des propositions que vous souhaitez
formuler ce matin
je me tourne maintenant vers Justin
panfil alors maire du Laurin en
Martinique et puis vous êtes le
président de l'Association
Départementale des des Mair c'est un
constat partagé est-ce que aujourd'hui
chez vous il y a une crise des voocation
ou est-ce que aujourd'hui encore il y a
des des maires et et des maires qui tout
en étant engagé se posent des questions
voudraz voir des des incertitudes se
lever enfin bonjour à à toutes et à tous
non je je dirais pas qu'il y a une crise
d'évocation je pense que l'engagement
lui-même est quelque chose de de
formidable à partir du moment où on sait
qu'on s'engage et qu'on est au service
des autres ça c'est une première chose
je je me suis parfaitement retrouvé
parfois sur les les éléments présenté
par le le svipov parce qu'effectivement
sur la question de la retraite sur la
question de l'activité professionnelle
et puis sur les difficultés que l'on
rencontre dans le quotidien on est
effectivement confronté à cette
réalitélà j'ai eu la chance dans ma vie
d'être engagé très jeune j'ai été maire
j'avais 35 ans ça fait 20 15 ans
aujourd'hui que je suis maire mais élu
local depuis une vingtaine d'années et
j'avoue qu'effectivement ce qui a
traversé ces 20 ans c'est la je dirais
la la difficulté de concilier à la fois
une vie professionnelle active et une
vie je dirais de maire engagé présent et
qui participe activement avec les
services à à la mise en œuvre des
politiques publiques et puis des projets
que l'on apporte porter au devant de la
population et qui l'a accepté moi ce qui
me me plaît dans ce thème qui est
présenté
aujourd'hui c'est un thème dans lequel
on se projette les difficultés et
comment effectivement réformer ou
transformer la fonction de mer moi ce
que je ne souhaiterais pas c'est que une
fois que ce débat soit
terminé que ça soit un beau débat et
qu'au bout du compte ça n'impacte pas
les les évolutions ou les réformes à
venir parce qu'il y a quelque chose
quand même qui me où je suis catastrophé
c'est on résume parfois la la
revalorisation de l'action du ma ou du
maire en lui en lui-même en revalorisant
les indemnités moi je trouve ça
catastrophique on ne vient pas pour
gagner de l'argent quand on est maire on
ne vient pas absolument pour gagner du
poignon c'est pas ça l'esprit et si on
pense qu'en révisant les indemnités
qu'on va renouveler l'évocation on se
trompe complètement parce que si c'est
simplement une question question
d'argent je pense que comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure en 2020 ceux qui ont
débuté le mandat 3 ou 4 4 mois après ont
vite vu que ça n'est pas du tout du tout
du tout la réalité d'un maire les
profils des maires ont changé
complètement totalement ça n'est plus
l'instituteur ça n'est plus le médecin
du village ou l'instituteur du village
ça n'est plus le retraité comme je l'ai
entendu tout à l'heure ça n'est plus non
plus une majorité de profession libéral
vous avez beaucoup de alors
effectivement de personnes actives
professionnellement qui s'engage et vous
avez quelquefois beaucoup de d'agents de
la fonction publique qui s'engage des
gens aussi qui connaissent la complexité
des des dossier à qui ça fait moins peur
et c'est un constat et on l'a vu lundi
lors de la réunion des des élus d'outre
mè ou vos collèguesi ils connaissent la
réalité dans les dans la fonction
publique et dans les le déroulement des
politiques publiques et sont confrontés
déjà dans leur activité professionnelle
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
quand ils sont dans l'activité ce que la
loi complexifie dans la mise en œuvre du
partenariat c'estàd faire en sorte que
l'on se retrouve avec de la démocratie
participative les partenaires sociaux
les obligation d'avis à rendre je
reviendrai pas sur la CdP NAF ça va
hériter certains ici que j'en parle mais
c'est une réalité quand vous avez un
avis un avis conforme sur le territoire
hexagonal et un avis un avis conforme en
territoire d'outrem et un avis simplifié
en territoire hexagonal la question
c'est est-ce que la responsabilité
s'écrite différemment éventuellement
mais c'est pas je ne l pas pour le maire
de saint-trroin est-ce que le mot
responsabilité s'écrit différemment
quand on est dans l'Hexagone que quand
on est dans les territoires d'outrem ça
s'écrit de la même manière là aussi
c'est le message au parlementaires
d'avoir des des des lois qui soient
simples et qui soit également on est sur
un territoire national un territoire qui
se veut un territoire unifié on ne peut
pas donc avoir deux écritures distinctes
du mode de fonctionnement de la loi sur
le territoire hexagonal et dans les
Territoires
d're alors les conditions
d'exercice on a la possibilité vous a
donné de vous exprimer et justement on a
avec vous nous dans dans dans cet
auditorium ce matin un adjoint au maire
qui a eu des difficultés très très
concrètes dans l'exercice de de son
mandat je rappelle
Laurent Rousell que vous étiez et vous
êtes encore adjoint au maire de de
Fontainebleau et puis aujourd'hui en
conflit avec votre employeur parce que
et ben il vous reproche votre engagement
et il reproche tout le temps que vous
passez à vous occuper des finances de
votre ville plutôt que de de votre
carrière mais arriver à un conflit
devant les les les prudesomes vous ne
l'imaginiez pas en vous engageant dans
la vie
municipale non tout à fait donc je suis
comme vous l'avez dit à joaner à
Fontainbleau et aussi premier
vice-président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération du Pays de Fontaineblau
et je travaille depuis près de 35 ans
dans une grande entreprise française
secteur bancaire j'en dirais j'en dirais
pas plus et effectivement j'ai souhaité
faire les choses dans les règles donc
j'ai informer mon mon employeur de de
mon engagement en le notifiant et là ça
a été le début des la dégradation de mes
relation professionnelle puisque ça m'a
été reproché de d'exercer un autre
mandat on on on m'a clairement dit écrit
d'ailleurs que c'était qu'il y avait
probablement une incompatibilité puisque
ça allait prendre beaucoup trop de temps
et cetera et cetera enfin bon les choses
se sont dégradées progressivement
progressivement j'ai été muté sans mon
accord on m'a enlevé toutes mes
responsabilités on m'a supprimé mes
pouvoirs bancaires et donc la situation
devenant intenable j'ai saisi les prudom
en me disant que j'allais pas me laisser
faire puisque clairement si j'avais
démissionné ça aurait peut-être arrangé
mon employeur mais j'avais pas
l'intention donc j'ai saisi les
prudommes et j'ai demandé une résolution
du contrat de travail au au tort de
l'employeur et j'ai invoqué la
discrimination selon la loi de 2019
décembre 2019 sur l'engagement local
voilà donc ça c'est ce que j'ai fait
sauf que c'était il y a plus de 2 ans
maintenant ça fait 2 ans et demi déjà
trois audiences une audience de
conciliation deux audiences de jugement
des renvois et cetera et cetera donc
l'audience de jugement a bien eu lieu
mais le délibéré ne sera rendu que l'an
prochain
mieux et peut-être même un an plus tard
si jamais les jurés ne se mettent pas
d'accord avec les délais de notification
plus les délais d'appel c'est
probablement encore 3 ou 4 ans de
procédure devant moi et c'est même à se
demander si ce sera jugé un jour parce
qu'après on peut toujours aller en
cassation enfin bref c'est c'est
totalement infini donc vous imaginez que
que ma vie au quotidien est devenue
assez compliqué à gérer et donc progress
parce qu' en l'occurrence quand on a un
engagement de de syndicaliste par
exemple on est reconnu comme travailleur
protégés et alors qu'il y a une grosse
ambigué il y en avait une en particulier
lorsque vous êtes engagé dans la vie
municipale alors alors tout à fait
puisque auparavant il y avait une
tentative d'avoir une protection des des
élus en 2015 2016 je sais plus
exactement la date et mais il y a eu une
une erreur en fait quand la loi a été
votée c'était dans le code des
collectivité territoriale mais c'était
pas dans le code du travail donc cette
loi a été finalement supprimée et une
nouvelle loi est arrivé en 2019 qui
stipule que quand on est élu local c'est
discriminatoire si on a des atteintes
sauf que la discrimination c'est très
compliqué à démontrer et en tous les cas
la procédure est très longue alors que
quand on est protégé il suffit d'aller
dans l'inspection du travail et puis ça
bloque ça bloque toutes les les
problèmes qu'on pourrait avoir là il
faut pouvoir le démontrer moi j'ai des
preuves écrites donc en théorie ça
devrait aller bien mais ça ne s'est pas
passer comme ça c'était assez compliqué
voilà justement on est vraiment sur des
points très concrets dé blocages qu'
faut lever et c'est tout le travail de
la Commission on va prendre d'autres
interventions monsieur allez-y vous vous
présentez s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup
bonjour à
tous micro an mquignon maire d'une
petite commune d'un Bour cent de 1000
habitants dans le Pas de Calais
département qui vient d'être très touché
et on pense à tousos collègues qui sont
dans la difficulté en ce moment et pour
témoigner et surtout pour expliquer les
difficultés et comment il est difficile
d'appliquer la loi et on n' pas le choix
entre en tant que maire dans le domaine
de l'urbanisme j'ai un concitoyen qui a
construit trois appartements dans une
zone plan de prévention des risques
inondation
rouge dans un périmètre architecte des
Bâtiments de
France sans permis de
construire je l'ai donc avec l'aide de
la communauté
d'agglomération avec notre inspecteur
assigné au tribunal en écrivant au
procureur en
2019 il est passé en septembre
2023 les appartements étaient quasi
terminés il vient d'y avoir 1 m d'eau à
l'intérieur il a été condamné à 900 €
pour participer au frais des de l'avocat
de la commune 1 € de domage et intérêt
et puis au
revoir comment comment montrer l'exemple
comment faire en sorte que nous soyons
respecter parce que nous faisons
respecter la loi deuxième petit
témoignage j'ai été insulté mais employé
aussi au début de l'année mais avec
menace de brûler la mairie j'ai déposé
plainte la personne est passée très
rapidement au tribunal elle a été
condamnée à 4 mois si elle a quitté le
département
elle neffectuera jamais sa peine elle
est partie ailleurs elle recommencera et
puis en partant elle m'a fait un beau
bras d'honneur en disant je
t'emmerdeon fa espérer son cas je pense
que c témoignage il monte je suis élu
depis 1989 j'ai fait un mandat de
conseiller municipal un mandat d'adjoint
c'est mon 4e mandat de mer ça n'a jamais
été aussi difficile merci de m'avoir
écouté
merci de ce
témoignage François Xavier ménage des
témoignages comme celui-là vous en avez
entendu dans la préparation de de votre
livre ce livre qui a pour titre ça
craque travail argent logement santé
vivre ensemble et vous êtes allé à la
rencontre de responsable d'association
de citoyens engagés et bien sûr de de
Mair et vous me disiez quand ont préparé
ce ce débat il souffre en silence mais
il ne reste pas les bras Ballan c'est le
constat que vous faites à l'écoute de de
ces élus locaux ouais ça craque mais
mais trois petits points et c'est toutes
les actions que vous menez que j'ai
voulu moi mettre en avant dans dans ce
bouquin je prends soin de préciser que
je ne suis que reporter ma religion
c'est le terrain point la ligne he donc
je n'ai aucun aucune opinion politique
en venant ici en revanche j'ai le souci
d'expliquer ce qui se passe sur le
terrain je pense que sans faire de
sermon on est en 2023 dans un pays qui
avance plus vite que nous tous on a du
mal à comprendre où habitent les autres
et on habite nous-mêm moi c'est la
matière première de ce livre et dans
cette matière première il y a les élus
les élus de terrain et je suis c'est
vrai sidéré de voir tout ce que vous
avez sur les épaules toutes les
casquettes que vous avez sur la tête qui
étaient probablement pas des casquettes
que vous aviez imaginé devoir porter et
qu'à force d'avoir des casquettes je
comprends que ça fasse mal au dos pour
dire les choses poliment euh j'ai
découvert ce qu'a fait le morbillant
c'est-à-dire quelc cul un taux de
démission de 15 % depuis les dernières
élections municipales c'est-à-dire et le
calcul avait été fait par la MF 56 d'un
taux de démission 5 fois supérieur au
secteur privé moi qui suis journaliste
ça m'a fait un électrochoc et je l'ai je
l'ai raconté dans ce livre et je pense
que ça a eu un certain écho parce que
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de personnes
m'en ont parlé ce que je veux dire aussi
c'est que j'ai été choqué par exemple
quand j'ai couvert les incendies en
Gironde en 2022 de voir un maire qui par
ailleurs a besoin de bosser comme
secrétaire de mairie dans deux autres
communes et qui par ailleurs aidait des
citoyens ses citoyens a évacuer des
maisons elle a dormi une demi-heure dans
une église qui s'était transformé en en
lieu de de QG pour les les pompiers
rappelez ce travail dans la gestion de
crise au plus près de nos habitants de
nos concitoyens exctement et et parce
qu'elle a dormi une demi-heure il y a
sur les réseaux sociaux des personnes
qui ont dit mais quel espèce de feignas
je pense que ça choque et le citoyen que
je suis le journaliste que je suis je
pense qu'on se doit de raconter ça après
chacun se fera sa propre opinion mais ce
type de propos dans pareilles
circonstances où la France entière était
en train de se dire merde on a quand
même des incendies qui sont en train de
ravager une partie de la Gironde je
rappelle que le Président de la
République est venu sur place ces
parolesl elles doivent aussi d'une
certaine manière être représenté pour
que là encore chacun se pose les bonnes
questions moi c'est mon métier alors si
je fais ce ce ce constat là et vous le
connaissez tous mieux que moi alors on
va se dire tout est foutu sauf que les
élus que je vois sur le terrain qui ne
lève pas le doigt c'est pour ça que
c'est important que vous évoquiez cette
France silencieuse et c'est pas du tout
insultant ces élus qui avance sans tirer
la couette vers eux sans dire e oh il
faut une caméra là pour raconter ce que
je fais moi je fais en sorte quand c'est
possible d'aller justement vers ces élus
qui n'ont rien demandé entre guillemets
et aussi aussi mettre en avant ce qui
est fait au quotidien je pense notamment
et je l'ai découvert que il y a des élus
des adjoints qui vont retaper des écoles
qui vont les repeindre 3 jours avant la
rentrée des classe parce que s'ils font
pas ça ben l'école elle est pourrie je
pense à des
élus qui se battent à 20 km de Paris
pour que je pense à greini il y ait un
supermarché qui puisse ouvrir et que en
France dans la ville la plus pauvre de
France pendant des années visiblement il
y a une bonne nouvelle qui arrive et le
supermarché va pouvoir ouvrir pendant
des années dans la ville la plus pauvre
de France il y avait pas de supermarché
alors que nous dans les médias on évoque
la bataille de l'inflation et comment
trouver des produits pas chers dans les
rayons et bien dans des communes en
France de 30000 habitants il y avait pas
de supermarché et ces combats là qui
sont je pense àolitique il est important
de les
représentertique citoyens parce qu'il
s'agit aussi d'expliquer à nos
concitoyens ce qu'est la la vie
démocratique avec ses responsables de de
de proximité et de leur faire comprendre
aussi toute la la complexité de de ce
travail on va prendre une autre
intervention monsieur vous êtes devant
le micro donc c'est c'est à vous vous
présenter s'il vous plaît oui bonjour je
suis monsieur péter le maire d'une
petite commune de la
SAR Chagne 700 habitants
euh écoutez je d'abord bonjour à tous et
merci de nous laisser la parole il est
peu souvent ou un maire d'une petite
commune puisse
s'exprimer totalement librement et avec
un temps donné merci encore ce que je
veux dire c'est que effectivement on a
de grandes difficultés et le maire est
celui qui s'occupe de l'humain de ses
citoyens de ses agents on parle beaucoup
des secrétaires de mairie et qui
s'occupe qui a plusieurs casquettes et
je me suis retrouvé à avoir la casquette
de m'occuper d'un épad territorial et je
fais un focus là-dessus pour vous dire
qu'en ce moment je suis en grandees
difficulté parce que j'ai mis l'humain
en avant j'ai mis effectivement le
bien-être des résidents en avant j'ai
mis les conditions de travail et de vie
des personnels de soins en avant on les
a applaudi à un moment où effectivement
on était en grande difficulté ils ont
fait le
job maintenant on a tendance où la crise
covid est considéré comme passés on a
tendance à les oublier d'autant s'ils
sont dans la fonction
territoriale moi comme j'ai voulu les
soutenir j'ai voulu leur donner je
dirais un niveau pas les favorisés leur
donner un niveau identique à
l'Hospitalier et ben maintenant je suis
accusé
d'avoir abusé de mes pouvoir en quelque
sorte pour les avoir alignés sur
l'Hospitalier rien de plus donc de
reconnaître leur job voilà ce qui se
passe voilà les difficultés donc au
moment où il y a les 100 millions
d'euros qui sont donnés pour pouvoir
soutenir ces maires ces épades
territoriaux on va me dire bah Vous vous
n'aurez rien parce que vous avez déjà
commencé à les soutenir financièrement
alors que vous en aviez pas forcément
les moyens alors c'est toute la question
Monsieur le Maire de du de l'élu
employeur hein là encore dans une
responsabilité et puis ce ce thème très
particulier du vieillissement il y a
d'ailleurs un forum he pendant ces 3
jours qui est consacré à ce sujet et
puis il y a surtout une loi en
préparation et et bien évidemment vous
avez raison parce que c'est à l'échelle
locale que tout cela se se joue et c'est
bien ça tout tout tout l'enjeu qui est
devant nous Muriel Fabre avec toutes ces
situations très complexes que ça soit le
le le maire employeur le maire dans ses
politiques sociales le maire urbaniste
aménageur et des des des solutions à à
trouver ce travail à à faire aussi dans
un consensus et puis dans une
amélioration de la loi et du
Règlement effectivement moi je voudrais
juste revenir sur le débat et sur le le
statut de l'élu parce que en tant que
élu de de la génération 2020 on m'a
souvent rétorqué c'est un c'est un vieux
sujet mais si l'association des maères
de France s'en est saisie et a mis en
place ce groupe de travail c'est c'est
parce qu'on a bien eu conscience
qu'aujourd'hui on ne vit pas un mandat
comme les autres depuis 2020 c'est
finalement une succession de crise la
crise sanitaire on en a parlé la crise
économique on sera certainement face à
une crise sociale et c'est cette gestion
aujourd'hui que nous devons faire au
quotidien qui finalement est extrêmement
compliqué et et difficile on est aussi
en urgence attenta je pense qu'on ne
peut pas mettre oublier finalement ce ce
risque sécuritaire ce risque climatique
qui a été rappelé par notre collègue du
du Pas de Calais et finalement renforcé
aussi par
une République menacée on attaque les
symboles républicains on attaque les
élus mais on attaque nos hôtels de ville
on attaque nos écoles une démocratie
fragilisée vous l'avez rappelé avec un
taux d'abstention qui devient de plus en
plus prignant même pour les élections
municipales et qui finalement euh euh
mett en péril ce lien que nous avons
avec nos concitoyens mettre en
difficulté ce rapport que nous avons
avec nos citoyens alors que nous sommes
en proximité que nous sommes en première
ligne et c'est vrai que ce contexte avec
cette immédiateté des demandes que l'on
a et que lorsqu'on sait pu y répondre et
bien ça ça s'anime par violence par
doigt d'honneur et cetera et bien c'est
du quotidien c'est aussi finalement
toute cette inflation norm typ que nous
vivons en aujourd'hui avec je le
rappelle he en 20 ans plus de 73 % de
texte législatif en plus ce qui est
énorme et puis c'est me semble-t-il
certains collègues je vois les les les
les sénateurs présents certains
collègues leur avaient dit que on vivait
un harcèlement textuel voyez les mots
forts que nous avons comme les mots
forts de notre congrès ce n'est pas pour
rien qu'on les utilise aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on a vraiment le sentiment
d'être démuni d'être isolé et finalement
total décourager et puis ce finalement
cette bureaucratie qui qui nous anime au
quotidien c'est ce nombre de circulaires
ce nombre de mails ces règlements tous
ces éléments qu'il faut comprendre qu'il
faut appréhender pour pouvoir mettre en
œuvre finalement nos politiques
publiques et bien c'est une
responsabilité aussi qu'on a une
responsabilité juridique une
responsabilité judiciaire qu'on peut
avoir aussi en tant que MRE employeur
quand on essaie finalement de de mettre
en œuvre tous ces éléments là et je
pense que ça complexifie aussi la donne
et c'est extrêmement important de
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui oui on a envie
d'agir oui on a envie de faire oui on ne
le fait pas pour l'argent mais on a
besoin de solution parce que demain ce
sont un ce sont des engagements citoyens
qu'on ne retrouvera plus en fait on aura
plus de maire on aura plus de d'adjoints
on aura plus de conseill municipal qui
voudront se représenter en 2026 parce
que face à tout cela face à toute cette
inflation normative face à ces
injonctions contradictoires on l'a dit
tout à l'heure vous l'avez souligné
aujourd'hui on nous demande de
construire du logement on nous demande
de réindustrialiser notre territoire et
tout cela avec moins foncier alors les
solutions on va en parler on va voir
justement comment on peut agir comment
on peut progresser en la matière on va
remercier les élus qui ont témoigné ce
matin vous remerciez aussi François
Xavier ménage en rappelant votre livre
ça craque je crois d'ailleurs que que
vous êtes présent sur le salon à
l'espace librairie j'ajoute juste une
toute petite chose parce que souvent on
peut ne pas bien se comprendre entre
journaliste et élu ou alors voire même
ne pas avoir de de lien ou de contact
moi je remercie le bon Dieu d'avoir des
portables de m avec qui je peux parler
quand il y a un enjeu national mon
premier réflexe c'est pas d'appeler un
cabinet ministériel c'est d'appeler des
maires pour leur demander juste où ils
en sont comment ils perçoiv les choses
et après je me fais moi-même évidemment
ma propre opinion de journaliste mais
c'est fondamental d'avoir ces liens là
et c'est pas du populisme à de bal que
de parler comme ça on a besoin de votre
expertise j'insiste à politique sur des
questions des en je où c'est le
territoire qui parle donc vraiment merci
d'être là parce qu'on a besoin de vous
voilà merci François Xav ménage vous
stéan gu chameille vous m'autorisez un
dernier mot je crois que vous avez
raison l'enjeu c'est que qu'il y ait des
gens qui a envie d'exercer ses fonctions
en 2026 donc vraiment j'insiste on n'est
pas là pour se plaindre on demande juste
de pouvoir bénéficier de conditions
normales pour exercer nos mandats et
j'espère qu'en 2026 on aura suffisamment
réenchanté la fonction pour que plein de
gens de bonne volonté de consensus et de
vraie démocrates et envie de et envie de
se présenter de gérer nos communes
merci on va passer maintenant à une
deuxème séquence de notre débat quel
levier pour améliorer l'attractivité du
mandat
voilà et pour en parler bien sûr nous
sommes toujours avec Muriel Fabre et
puis avec les les coprésidents de ce
groupe de travail avec les propositions
qu' ont été formulé dans dans ce groupe
Catherine lerritier Frédéric rag nous
sommes toujours aussi avec Martial
foucot qui a permis de de de formuler
aussi les diff difficulté mais de partir
et de pouvoir progresser sur des des
solution très concrète et j'invite à
nous rejoindre Françoise Gattel
sénatrice d Villen et présidente de la
délégation sénatorial aux collectivités
territoriales et à la
décentralisation qui est chez elle à la
MF parce que ancienne présidente de la
commission de l'intercommunalité en
particulier David Valence député de la
2e circonscription des desvuges
président de la délégation à la
décentralisation de l'Assemblée
nationale et lui aussi longtemps élu
local à saint-ier desves
et puis avec nous Rémy Lefèvre
politologue professeur des
universitaires des universités prof à
l'EP de de Lille et vous avez travaillé
sur le statut de l'élu sur les
conditions d'exercice et vous avez des
propositions à faire peut-être des des
propositions qui seront convergente avec
celle de l'Association des des des
maires parce que effivement Frédéric rag
après le constat et bien il
faut prendre une une liste très très
diverse on l'a déjà un peu vu là dans la
première partie de notre débat avec tous
les les les aspects on a dit les les
irritants mais aussi tout ce qui sont
autant d'obstacles sur la route du maire
et de l'élu local
aujourd'hui bien
sûr je je voudrais dire d'abord que il
faut lever les tabou on a travaillé sans
tabou ça a été dit dans le débat
précédent on on demande pas des
privilèges être élu c'est pas un
privilège c'est le résultat du suffrage
universel qui est extraordinaire et que
les gens ont exprimé au travers de leur
vote et donc on n pas ici des
privilégiés dans cette salle pas plus
que dans les 35000 communes à
l'extérieur et donc il faut que mesdames
Messieurs les parlementaires vous
puissiez passer cet obstacle là de dire
on demande pas une France à plusieurs
vitesses et il y aurait d'un côté les
citoyens de l'autre les élus non dans le
groupe de travail ça a été exprimé ce
matin on demande simplement la
reconnaissance de la responsabilité que
le suffrage universel nous confie et que
le gouvernement demande souvent au mère
c'est celui qui est là qui est à
proximité on l'a vu sur le covid on l'a
vu pour les gilets jaunes on l'a vu pour
tout un tas de de crises qu'on a
traversé qui sait qu'on voit sur la
lucarne le disait le journaliste tout à
l'heure c'est le maire le premier qui
est sur un événement c'est le maire et
donc ça ça demande effectivement parfois
peut-être de la reconnaissance mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'on le fait ça
demande la capacité de pouvoir agir et
donc dans notre groupe de travail
effectivement le sujet de la formation
bien évidemment est important parce
qu'on est rentré de plein fer dans ce
mandat avec le covid et donc on n pas pu
avoir un début de mandat normal être
aussi un peu parrainé par les amis la le
sujet du temps et l'indamnité elle est
secondaire l'indemnité elle est
simplement la réflexion ça a été de dire
l'indemnité
euh on peut pas avoir une perte
économique liée au fait que on s'est
engagé au service de l'intérêt général
et et donc du coup à un moment donné il
faut que l'indemnité soit un juste
équilibre c'est pas un salaire et c'est
pas un métier d'être élu et donc c'est
toujours une indemnité qui doit
compenser des frais et puis bien
évidemment toute la question liée au
statut des crédit heurs des
autorisations d'absence qui
effectivement sont très compliqués ça a
été dit dans un témoignage souvent on
peut pas les prendre et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on grignote sur nos congés euh on
grignote sur notre temps pour pouvoir
effectivement exercer notre mandat et
puis euh la question de l'attractivité
bien évidemment euh comment rendre la
lisibilité d'un mandat attractif pour
les jeunes les des étudiants par exemple
hein comment peuvent-ils s'engager alors
que parfois ils sont très loin de leur
commune pour exercer cette possibilité
pourquoi il y aurait de tabou les
personnes handicapées et bien entendu il
faut continuer le combat pour la cause
féminine euh on on est on est souvent en
en difficulté on voit sur les estrades
même si des lois sur la parité et cetera
ont été mis c'est très compliqué dans
tous les témoignages qu'on peut avoir
pour les femmes de s'engager
effectivement dans la vie politique
voilà donc ça c'est pendant le mandat et
puis après le mandat vous l'avez évoqué
il y a la question des retraites mais il
y a également la question de la
reconnaissance de la personnal de la
responsabilité qu'on a et de la reprise
souvent quand vous encadrez les
personnels quand vous gérez euh des
centaines de milliers d'euros d'argent
public quand vous gérez des marchés
publics quand vous engagez votre
responsabilité tout ça c'est une
expérience qui est acquise et ça fait
aujourd'hui pchit le jour où vous n'êtes
plus élus et donc c'est pas normal
qu'effectivement ça ne soit pas un
élément de valeur ajoutée pour permettre
à des élus de pouvoir après leur vie
d'élu pouvoir reprendre une activité
professionnelle ou valoriser ce qu'ils
ont acquis pendant l'exercice de leur
mandat et donc après ce tout cet
inventire des des propositions des
propositions très concrètes mais qui
doivent se traduire sous souvent par des
évolutions législatives et c'est là que
les deux chambres du Parlement
interviennent avec David Valence un
travail qui a été lancé je rappelle que
que vous êtes président de la délégation
à la décentralisation de l'Assemblée
nationale et que vous avez lancé à
l'Assemblée nationale une mission
d'information là aussi peut-être pour
progresser et trouver la la traduction
législative à tous ces problèmes qu'on
évoque depuis ce matin et qu'on a déjà
évoqué hier en ouverture du du Congrès
quand il s'agit aussi de la sécurité
physique des élus et de de la prise de
de de risque et on a eu des témoignages
qui étaient vraiment poignant oui
d'abord merci Jean d'avoir rappelé que
j'ai été mère pendant 8 ans et et je
pense que c'est une expérience dans une
vie publique qui est vraiment fondatrice
je pense qu'on pourrait dire mère un
jour mère toujours en tout cas il faut
toujours se souvenir de ce qu'on a vécu
quand on était maire et je l'étais dans
un un bassin d'emploi et dans une ville
en transition avec beaucoup de friches
industriell et où il y avait un un très
gros travail à faire qui se poursuit
avec mon équipe municipale euh moi je
voudrais avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet de parler de la mission
d'information dont vous que vous avez
évoqué qui est qui a été confié à à mes
collègues violettes spelbout et et
Sébastien Jumel mission d'information
sont avec nous ce matin et on leur
donnera la la parole ce matin mission
d'information qui a qui a commencé ses
travaux au mois de septembre et qui les
remettra d'ici quelques jours maintenant
quelques semaines avant les vacances de
de de Noël et qui se consacre à
l'ensemble des aspects du statut de
l'élu je voudrais dire que le le
vocabulaire est important quand on parle
des maires je lisais encore ce matin un
article de journal qui disait les maires
c'est les gardesfous de la République on
parle souvent des piliers et je crois
qu'à force d'utiliser des des métaphores
comme ça qui sont un peu statiques on a
fini par oublier que ce rôle du maire il
évolue et on a fini par ce cette table
ronde ici au Congrès des Maires de
France une table ronde sur l'engagement
de l'élu local un engagement toujours
plus exigeant c'est la fin de cette
émission spéciale ici Porte de
Versailles à Paris au Congrès des Maires
de France prochain rendez-vous sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat à 15h pour les
questions d'actualité du Sénat au
gouvernement les sénateurs auront
beaucoup de questions sur les
préoccupations des maires et puis je
vous donne rendez-vous ici à 17h pour
une nouvelle émission spéciale sur ce
congrès des maires de France on parlera
de la hausse des violences contre les
élus locaux très bonne suite des
programmes sur public
[Musique]
scena voir ou revoir votre
programme sur
publsenat.fr tout de suite sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat le péril jeune les randonneurs la
vérité siement il a marqué toute une
génération avec ses rôles au cinéma
rempliis de bonne humeur et de légèreté
aujourd'hui il fait partie des les
acteurs qui n'hésitent pas à tenter
l'aventure de la série sur les
plateformes Vincent Elbas est notre
invité dans un monde un regard les
entretiens de Public Sénat un monde un
regard vendredi à 17h30 sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver on est ensemble comme
tous les jours pendant 1 heure et dem on
fait le point sur l'actualité prês de
chez vous on regarde ensemble le
programme dans une demi-heure notre
invité ce sera Jean-François Copé le
maire les républicains de mot dans le
club des territoires on reviendra sur la
projection des images de l'attaque
terroriste du Hamas qui avait lieu hier
soir au Sénat et on parlera de la
situation des otages un accord a été
trouvé cette nuit sur une trêve
humanitaire en échange de libération
d'otage on sera avec le sénateur Francis
piner et le journaliste George malbruno
et pour commencer nous sommes avec le
sénateur centriste lis carvé bonjour
merci d'être avec nous lis kvé vous êtes
memre de la commission des affaires
étrangères vous nous direz pourquoi vous
avez choisi de ne pas assister à la
projection hier soir et puis on parlera
également avec vous du Congrès des mares
qui s'est ouvert hier et ce discours
attendu d'Élisabeth borne demain d'abord
on regarde ensemble les repères de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 22
[Musique]
novembre Israël approuve un accord
visant à obtenir la libération de 50
Otages aux mains du Hamas en échange de
prisonniers palestiniens et d'une trêve
de 4 jours mais Isra prévient cet accord
ne signifie pas la fin de la guerre Yan
et
F après 6 semaines d'angoisse enfin
l'espoir pour les otages et leur famille
environ 240 personnes ont été enlevées
le 7 octobre le Hamas et Israël
confirment avoir chacun trouvé un accord
pour la libération d'une cinquantaine
d'entre eux le gouvernement a approuvé
les grandes lignes de la première étape
d'un accord selon lequel au moins 50
personnes enlevé des femmes et des
enfants seront libérés pendant 4 jours
au cours desquels il y aurait une
acalmie dans les combats
une trêve négociée conjointement par le
Qatar qui travaille depuis des semaines
avec les États-Unis et l'Égypte le début
de cette pause sera annoncée dans les
prochaines 24 heures et durera 4 jours
sous réserve de prolongation dans
l'accord figure en contrepartie la
libération de prisonniers palestiniens
10 otages contre 30 prisonniers des
jeudi annonce un haut responsable du
Hamas mais ces premiers signes de répis
ne signifient pas la fin des combats
Israël confirme sa volonté d'éliminer le
à l'issue de la trêve et les terroristes
ne désarmment pas les dispositions de
cet accord ont été formulées
conformément à la vision de résistance
nous confirmons que nos mains resteront
sur la gâchette et que nos bataillons
triomphants resteront aux AG Joe Biden
se dit ce matin extraordinairement
satisfait par
l'accord et hier soir Ava au sén la
projection du film montrant les attaque
terroriste du Hamas le 7 octobre dernier
les sénateurs en sont ressortis marqués
Jérôme Rabier ils sont une cinquantaine
de sénateurs à avoir répondu présent
pour assister à la projection du film de
l'armée israélienne montrant les
massacre du Hamas du 7 octobre une
diffusion à H clos chacun devant laisser
son téléphone portable à l'entrée c'est
le président du groupe d'amitié France
Israël du Sénat qui en était
l'organisateur et pour ceux qui étaient
là la nécessité d'y assister pour
témoigner c'est parce que je crois que
nous devons accepter de voir la réalité
même si elle est difficile à regarder
même si elle va nous imposer probblement
des moments difficiles mais nous sommes
là parce que nous devons aussi faire
comprendre au monde ce qui s'est
vraiment passé le 7 octobre en Israël
une version de 52 minutes a été projeté
et à la sortie un silence total et une
émotion palpable mais j'ai simplement vu
jusqu'où l'homme pouvait perdre l'âme ni
plus ni moins
c'est il y a pas de mot voilà c'est
c'est c'est pas des hommes qui ont fait
ça c'est
terrible il sera le seul sénateur à
s'exprimer à notre micro les autres
choisissant de ne pas le faire
immédiatement trop marqué par cette
diffusion ou ne voulant pas réagir à
chaud à un montage difficilement
soutenable selon les mots de sénateur
hor
camer neuf suspects interpellés hier
pour le le meurtre de Thomas lycéen de
16 ans tué ce weekend lors d'une RCK
dans le village de